[Music]
have you ever wanted a shield so strong
that a golden lionel's heavy crusher
attack bounces off like nothing then
fire off a supercharged bow of light
that hits 10 times in a row
then finish off with a master sword
that's three times as powerful as a
normal master sword well this is now a
reality and no this is not a mod this
can be done on any nintendo switch so
today i'll teach you the simplest way to
pull this off yourself and more
importantly why this works because the
technical magic behind this is absurd if
you enjoy these types of tutorials and
explainers let us know with a like we
enjoy showing why stuff works not just
how to do it now let's jump right in
first things first trust me on this
you're going to want to make a new file
preferably start a new file on the
opposite difficulty or if you don't want
to overwrite that file either you can
just make a brand new profile there is
technically a way to do this on your
existing profile with your full
inventory but trust me on this when i
say it's less complex and easier to do
with this new game method and if you do
it my way with the same profile on the
opposite difficulty you can actually
transfer your overpowered equipment onto
your main save later so no biggie now
let's go ahead and start the new game
[Music]
but let's lay some ground rules one
dying is okay here there's no stress
compared to other harder glitches just
keep up where you left off if things go
south secondly do not pick up any arrows
armor or korok seats arrows are
especially bad because even having times
zero of them in one slot will ruin what
we're doing if you accidentally nabbed a
korok or an armor piece you can at least
use it or sell it later but just to make
it easy don't pick them up this is
because all these item slots interfere
with this glitch and you can get all
these after we're done corrupting
anyways so there's no rush to grab them
right now finally try to hoard materials
as much as possible just grab anything
you can along the way at least two of
each if you can our end goal is at least
62 different materials so start farming
right away to start you can either head
out like normal or clip out like most
speed runners do either is totally fine
clipping out is nice because it freezes
the time of day which makes traversing
the world less stressful so it's up to
you then complete the gray plateau as
normal once you've completed the gray
plateau check to make sure you still
have no arrows then go ahead and turn in
your four spirit orbs to the goddess
statue for hearts or stamina doesn't
matter and then head straight to hoteno
village
[Music]
this might be tricky because you have no
arrows and you can't use wind bombs or
blss so zero blss an alternate blss with
no arrows is the only other option but
this can be tricky to those who don't
understand it don't sweat it too much
instead just grab a horse or take a nice
hike once you get to maya magana shrine
unlock the shrine to be able to warp to
it this will now be our central hub to
come back to after farming for materials
now let's take a look at our inventory
our final goal here is to have one throw
away one-handed weapon one throw away
shield whatever equipment you want to
corrupt in my case i choose a royal bow
at least 62 ingredients with at least
two of each kind i like to have around
65 personally 60 meals total and our
chica slate and paraglider nothing else
in the key items take your time to
collect all these together i recommend a
pot lid and ladle in town if you need to
throw away equipment you'll want to
track down and grab the equipment for
what you want to corrupt i'm using the
royal bow and use normal gathering
amiibos incentory mountain for materials
and at least 60 apples
then go ahead and cook 59 apples to fill
up your meal slots one last step you'll
want to cook is a 60th target meal for
my example here i'm going with a silent
shroom and four swift carrots once you
cook them it should be in the last slot
that's where we want it
i'll link a google document in the
description below to what recipes are
possible more on this later once you
have everything in order save your game
this will be your main save you use as
backup in case anything goes wrong
now head to the general store in hiteno
village we're going to do a trick called
aeroless offset
first stand still jump and press bomb
once to drop your square bomb on the
ground
then pull out your weapon now hold zl
and press a and d-pad left in quick
succession if you see link starting to
put away his weapon go ahead and unequip
your shield if you did this correctly
you'll now see his weapon on his head
along with the bomb if he did this too
slow it'll be on his back so try again
go ahead and press r to throw then
re-equip your shield part 2 gets a
little tricky now you want to hold zl
again and don't let go until i tell you
to pause the game and hold four
different items and the fifth one should
be one ingredient by itself this is your
check ingredient you're going to keep
picking back up to make sure you do all
this right press d-pad right and unequip
your weapon or go to another one-handed
weapon if you did all of this correctly
you'll have the shield the weapon and
five ingredients all in your hands at
the same time now jump in the air then
let go of zl and start pause buffering
with the left d-pad you're now looking
for when link starts to put away the
shield when this animation starts to
play unequip the shield
if you did all this correctly you'll now
have five items and the weapon in your
hand now this next part is kind of tough
you want to tap whistle then talk to the
store owner as fast as humanly possible
i personally like to hold zl as i do
this to make sure that i'm facing him go
to sell items to see if you did this
right if you did this part quick enough
your fifth check item you held will be
grayed out and have time zero this is
the green light to go ahead and totally
sell the other four items you held in
your hands if you don't see the fifth
item at all that means you talk to this
guy too slowly and you'll have to start
over so in case of a failure pick up
your materials off the ground and let's
do this arrowless offset quickly one
more time
[Music]
each complete item you sell with this
glitch creates one offset slot the goal
here is to create 62 offset slots this
is to cover all 60 meals and two key
items in our menu so with this method
you'll have to do an average of 16 times
to reach 62. make absolutely sure you
keep track of each sail as doing this
for a while can cause you to easily lose
track once you're sure you have offset
62 slots you're finally ready to perform
the fun part the weapon modifier
corruption first let's clean up the menu
you now want to drop every material you
have left don't keep any of them on you
now you'll also want to drop any
equipment between your first meal and
your target equipment in this case it's
my royal bow since my pot lid is between
it and the meals i'll just have to toss
it on the ground make sure your target
recipe is still the last meal and we're
ready to go go ahead and get an autosave
often going back up to maya magana
shrine does this for you but you may
have to run around for a while to get
one this will save the inventory as it
looks right now in the autosave now go
ahead and reload the autosave you just
created
and there you go upon arrival you can
now meet your new powerful bow to
prevent further offset issues i suggest
getting another autosave and closing the
game entirely this will clear the glitch
and keep this weapon scot-free
[Music]
if you're happy with just this bow
you're now done but if you want to
transfer this bow back in time to your
manual save or to your main other save
this is what you do
eat all of your meals
rummage around for three materials to
create three offset slots
then load your manual save
[Music]
or return the title and load your main
save if it is going to your main file
just make sure that you have the room
for it
[Music]
foreign
so voila now you're back with all of
your goodies ready to go with your nice
fancy bow
okay so you went through all this red
tape to get this awesome weapon but how
did this even happen why did the offset
slots 60 meals and weapon placement even
matter well let me explain
first you've probably run into this
issue before if you played the game long
enough you know you can't have more than
60 meals that's just a cold hard fact
keep this in mind when we're ready to do
this glitch our inventory should have
the equipment we want to power up the 60
meals and two key items and at this
point the 62 offset slots we just made
when we're ready to corrupt our
equipment the magic begins first we have
our autosave we just got and our main
inventory and like i explained in our
previous ist video the game first
deletes everything in the file up to the
first meal because it is protected by
the offset slots we just made
then the game starts to load the
autosave you just selected first it
loads in your equipment including the
royal bow then your first meal
wait a second you already have 60 meals
in this file already you can't fit
anymore so what does the game do with
this meal well it does delete the meal
but it doesn't delete the meals values
also known as cook data this property
contains shortcut codes to the meals
prices effects parts etc are then
forcefully pushed onto whatever
equipment is next in your inventory in
this example we just did a bit earlier
it was our royal bow cooked data and
weapon data look like this side by side
see how these two line up over each
other this is the value of heart
recovery of a meal which is called
stamina recover x translating over to m
add value the additional power of the
said weapon the more hearts it heals the
stronger the power and in this line of
set cook effect 1 is your rupee selling
price which is then pushed onto m at
type the type of modifier your weapon
has this is super important and i'll
explain why in a second
this will now continue to do this over
and over 60 times until the last meal is
added the one we specifically cooked for
this the steamed mushrooms now this is
permanently written over your weapon
making the zooming multi-shot royal bow
finally the sheikah slate and paraglider
are loaded and last but are overwritten
because they can't duplicate
[Music]
now how does this cooking data possibly
make these overpowered weapons
let's work with a simple meal we had
before the steamed mushrooms this meal
is worth 60 rupees while you sell it
this number is in what you call normal
decimal notation you know normal numbers
when you force this number onto a weapon
it goes through three translations one
it first translates this decimal number
into hexadecimal notation a system that
uses letters and numbers you've probably
seen this number while working with
color codes on most programs so the 60
rupee value is now 3c
then it translates this hexadecimal
notation into binary notation a system
that consists of only ones and zeros
these ones and zeros very simplified are
forms of on or off for a computer i'll
link a converter in the description if
you want to mess around with this for
yourself so 3c translates into 111100
finally this binary number is then
inputted into breath of the wild's
weapon modifier system and there are
nine possible modifiers guard up surf up
quick shot zoom multi shot long throw
critical hit durability up and attack
the meal prices binary number is one one
one one zero zero so that means whatever
this equipment is it now has the zoom
function multi shot long throw and
critical hit since durability and attack
are zero these functions are not enabled
as well as any other numbers that the
list didn't get to alright alright
before you get too excited it obviously
only works with these functions for the
equipment that it's capable of doing it
with so you won't get a shield with
extra zoom or a weapon that multi-shots
or something
the last piece of the puzzle is how much
you want to affect these stats all you
generally need to know is that if you
want more attack regard you want more
hearts
for surfing friction the less hearts
make it more slippery all the way down
to zero heart meals to make it almost a
non-stop surfing shield
long throw and quick shot are a little
weird the default speed for them is 1
000 for a thrown weapon and the maximum
heart healing is 120. so this translated
over makes the fastest you can throw a
weapon or draw a bow around 12 percent
of its original speed at best which
results in a weapon that goes barely
anywhere which is entertaining i guess
but worse is a bow that takes forever to
draw so not too useful
finally multi shot and zoom are pretty
straightforward there's no modifier that
changes them but two weird rules apply
zoom will turn your 10 shot wide bow
into a tension linear bow because
multi-shot zooming bows don't
technically exist it turns your bow into
a 10-shot nuke and absolutely demolishes
enemies and all multi-shot bows are all
10 shot except for naturally quick
shooting bows which shoots so fast that
not all 10 arrows have time to release
so it unfortunately shorts you a couple
arrows
this doesn't even all end here this goes
even farther
such as corrupting multiple weapons in a
row back to back using negative m count
using dragon parts to create even more
powerful recipes and even doing some
cook-ception of cooking a meal within a
meal such as the popular roasted bird
thigh which is impossible to hold
normally is forced into your arms
withhold prompt storage or hold prompt
entanglement to cook a custom meal to
get a custom rupee price for custom
modifiers this rabbit hole continues to
go deeper with weapon modifier
corruption that has been unlocked by the
breath of the wild community players
have been clamoring for a way to forge
your own weapon modifiers from the
beginning and now we have a way to do
that thanks to the glitch hunting
community to help break this down and of
course we are always here for your
breath of the wild fix so keep it here
on gamespot
you